In a world where zombie’s have already infected
every facet of pop culture
comes another zombie movie.
But this time...
it’s got Brad Pitt!
World War Z.
Get ready for the big-screen adaptation of
the best-selling novel that’s got everything
you loved about...
the title.
And nothing else.
A film with so many production problems, people
were genuinely surprised when it wasn’t
a complete disaster.
Meet Gerry Lane, he’s just your average
everyday
Super attractive
Scarf-wearing
Spanish-speaking
Airplane-piloting
Sharp-shooting
Skull-bashing
Armor-crafting
Arm-chopping
Prisoner-Interrogating
Surgery-doing
Slo-mo-vision-having
Antidote-making
Eagle-eyed
Stay-at-home Dad.
“All you do is make pancakes in the morning!"
"Yeah, but I'm really good at it."
Travel the globe with Brad Pitt and the film’s
screenwriters as they stumble from set-piece
to set-piece tied together by the flimsiest
evidence ever.
“There was a memo sent from this installation
that had the word zombie in it.
Do you know anything about it?"
"It was an email, not a memo."
Come on.
Watch Brad Pitt survive an unsurvivable apocalypse
thanks to a constant stream of life-saving
coincidences like...
never hitting traffic in the middle of mass
hysteria,
finding an RV with the keys and a loaded gun
inside,
this friendly mugger showing him where to
find medicine,
this friendly Mexican family taking him in
no questions asked,
these fast zombies who slow down as soon as
they’re about to catch him,
this small child head-shotting a zombie on
top of him,
this plane dropping a ladder down to save
him mid-takeoff,
this Israeli soldier killing a zombie about
to eat him,
surviving this car crash,
surviving this plane crash,
surviving this spike through his stomach,
and shooting up with a randomly picked virus
that happens to be curable while also serving
as zombie camouflage.
Wait, is that Matthew Fox?
So get ready for a by-the-numbers action movie
full of PG-13 violence
and none of these awesome things from the
book:
Man, what a waste of good source material.
Starring
these zombie movie cliches:
dead car batteries,
flickering lights,
shakey cam,
jump scares,
zombies banging on doors,
a kid with asthma,
accidental noises,
and
obligatory
Inceptions
Bwaas.
Brad Pitt Zombie Movie.
Man, all those reshoots must've cost a fortune.
How'd they pay for that?
Man, that
really makes me want a Coke.
Thanks for watching!
Be sure
to subscribe!